There have been many brilliant
minds who have lent their talents,
the committing and the solving of crime,
but none stands as supremely as that
of Sherlock Holmes with is unequaled.
Powers of reasoning deduction
and scientific application
homes was able to solve
the cases that are baffled the best of
Scotland Yard with his tweed suit cloth
cap and his black clay pipe.
The world's greatest sleuth has become
familiar to a new generation through
television and movie adaptations of
his many adventures in this week's by
graphics.
We have dug deep to uncover the private
world of the notoriously secretive Mr
Sherlock Holmes may well have been the
greatest detective living or dead is to
investigate the criminal minds,
but he was an extremely private genius
as a result of the study of his early
years as an exercise in
frustration for biographies.
On one of the few occasions that he
did open up about his family origins.
He mentioned to his ever loyal sidekick,
James Watson,
that his ancestors were country squires
who up here to have that much the same
life as it's natural to
people of that class.
He also revealed that his
grandmother was the sister of Mlg,
Horace Vernay,
the renowned French artist who
specialized in the military paintings.
His final familiar revelation
was that he had an older brother,
Mycroft,
who according to show lock in self
possessed even greater powers of deduction
than he did.
Apart from those few tidbits,
we are left to work out
the details of homes,
his early life from circumstantial
evidence and deduction.
Something of a coincidence I might think.
Holmes was born and raised in the
county of Sussex on the south coast of
England.
The homeless family seat was that Linford,
a few miles from portion sherlock's.
Father,
a gentleman named roderick
homes was born around 18,
15.
Roderick was a man's man who delighted
in such outdoor pursuits as fox hunting,
trout fishing and pheasant shooting
in sharp contrast to his two sons.
He didn't put much credence in book
learning and affairs of the minds.
Shallock's mother was 13 years
younger than her husband's Charlotte.
Aircraft came from Lancashire,
but origins were French from her
mother's to see all their names.
She inherited not only artistic leanings,
but a flighty self-absorbed personality.
The marriage,
it was not a happy one,
and with such disparate personalities,
it could be said that it
was doomed from the start.
Their first child was born in 18,
46 and given the name
of John Microsoft homes,
the name gives us an insight into the
state of the parent's mental processes.
Roderick hated his own name and wanted
to give his firstborn son a plane on
complicated name,
but Charlotte has quite the opposite view.
She wanted to name that was different,
striking and memorable.
Of course,
Roderick one,
Charlotte managed to squeeze her choice
and Amalgam of possessive nature,
my with the last syllable of her maiden
name cropped in as a middle name.
It was only because he spends more of
his formative years around his possessive
mother that the boy came to be known
as Mycroft a name which grated on his
father.
Every time he heard it,
it took Roderick and Charlotte seven
years to produce another child's no
surprise considering the
deteriorating state of their union.
By now,
roderick has given up entirely on trying
to control his wife's autistic or as he
sort irrational site.
He left anything up to her and she even
out did a creativity the first time
around,
she named a second son,
Sherlock.
The name wasn't entirely her own
invention in order to escape from the
increasing abuse of our husbands who
had taken more and more to the bottle,
she began making trips to London where
she would visit art galleries and theater
performances.
She became enamored with a father and son,
pair of English artists,
both who were named William Sherlock in
the hopes that our seconds would prove
to be a great artist.
She gave him the Monica Sherlock
was the customer of the day to
send sons away to boarding school.
Roderick didn't believe
in higher education,
and so the two brothers
endured a succession of tutors,
some of whom were good,
while others were terrible,
even when they did have a good teacher.
Now,
volatile environments cost by the parents
losing for one another did not make
for conductive learning.
However,
Microsoft and sherlock
educated themselves,
despite their environments,
it seemed became apparent
that both boys were brilliant.
Sherlock instantly fell in love with
books later referring to himself as an
omnivorous reader.
His brother,
meanwhile,
was obsessed with numbers even though
there was a seven year gap in age,
the two boys were extraordinarily close.
They drew up on each other for mutual
support and mental stimulation,
Microsoft periods,
or an overweight child.
You avoided any type of
exercise or physical exertion.
Instead in his early teens,
he became fascinated with
electricity and chemistry.
This soon caught the attention
of his younger brother.
He began saving as pocket money to
buy scientific Kratos shut look,
escapes the unpleasant
environments at home.
By finding interests outside the house,
he developed a friendship with a man who
was in charge of his father's hunting
house.
This man named Sherman was a taxidermist
and shell expense many hours watching
him at work.
The boy also spends a lot of
time in his father's stables.
Rate.
Develops a great acquiring knowledge.
Unlike his brother,
Sherlock,
enjoyed sports.
He became a talented young boxer winning
a number of matches against local boys.
Roderick,
during his sober periods,
tried his best,
send the boys into country.
Squire's,
though they both became possible
shots with fouling pieces.
Neither of them had any
stomach for fox hunting.
Furthermore,
Mycroft was a poor horse rider.
One Constellation for Roderick though
was that they both took to fishing.
What they really relished was the
consultative nature of the activity,
which provided plenty of
time for planning overall.
However,
Roderick was disappointed in
how his sons were turning out,
unsurprisingly then he very
rarely showed them any affection,
preferring to cast aspirations on their
manhood and their physical prowess.
This lack of physical display was more
than compensated for by Charlotte who
would shower the boys with hugs
and kisses at every opportunity.
This only served to further strengthen
roderick's conviction that he had raised
a couple of cities when
our sons were old enough.
Charlotte took them to London where she
introduced them to concerts and opera
and guided them through the picture
galleries of the metropolis.
The brothers found out chatter,
tiresome and their behavior
sometimes embarrassing,
but they were grateful to
get away from their father.
As a result of these London visits,
shallow developed a strong love of music.
This inspired Charlotte to hire
a violin teacher for the boy,
but the lessons they didn't last long.
When Roderick found out about it,
he put an immediate stop to the lessons
Mycroft and Charlotte Gossett and spends
a lot of time with other
boys in the community.
They found them not to be up
to their intellectual level,
and so I've spent most
of their time together.
However,
they did make one great friends and
that would be Charles Edward Howard.
Vincent Charles was the son of Sir
Frederick Vincent Rector of the parish of
slim fit.
This boy was just as
brilliant as the homes boys.
He was sent off to boarding school at age
12 that spends most of his time during
the school vacations in the company of
Mycroft and Sherlock Charles Howard.
Vincent winds onto four j
distinguished multifaceted Korea,
which fills two pages in Britain's
dictionary of national biography.
Roderick refused to send his oldest son
to university when Microsoft reached the
age of 20,
but by now the older brother had enough
of his father's abusive ways and team
moved to London where he secured a
position as an assistant to a member of
parliaments.
When his brother moved away.
Sherlock was 13 years of age.
He spent an unhappy few years as
a loner in an unhappy household,
is only bright spots being the regular
letters that he received from his brother
in London and surprisingly at age 18,
Sharla convinced his father to
send them to Cambridge University.
During his first semester,
he was invited by a fellow students by
the name of Victor Trevor to spends the
vacation with him that his family's
estate and Norfolk not jeans.
You returned to his fueling parents.
He gladly accepted the
invitation following this visit.
Sherlock did not return
home for future holidays,
but took rooms in London where he
buried himself in chemical research.
He had his mind set on becoming a chemical
analyst while the university homes
played no part in team sports which would
have required cooperation with others.
Instead,
he focused on boxing.
The only friends he had
at college was Victor,
trevor,
just as the only friends he
had as an adult was Dr Watson
in the autumn of 18,
74 shallow to be on his third
year of study at Cambridge,
but he left before the year was out.
With no degree.
The details have never been revealed,
but it is clear that some
sort of trauma afflicted,
both sherlock and Mycroft during these
months and left psychological wounds on
both of them.
Biographers have speculated that the
situation may have involved members of the
opposite sex.
Dr Watson later shed some
light on the homes mindset.
His aversion to women and
is disinclination to form
new friendships were very
typical of his unemotional character,
but not more so than his complete
suppression of every reference to his own
people.
Homes himself once said,
I am not a whole sold
admirer of womankind.
Women are never to be entirely trusted,
not the best of them.
Despite this homes was always
courteous and considerate to women,
is hostility to the other.
Sex was confined to the
areas of love and marriage,
so whatever the precise
nature of this emotional blow,
it resulted in sherlock being
a lifelong user of narcotics.
This addiction was in sharp contrast to
his temperance and otherwise clean mode
of living at the time the use of narcotics
in Britain was neagle still have.
It was alarming to Dr Watson.
He wanted more than one occasion,
tried to reason with the great detective,
but it was a mind of destroying completely
wasteful and individual practice.
Homes usually brushed him
off about it over the years,
but with Watson's help,
he was able to have limited success in
shaking off the habits whether the tragic
events was separate to the death of homes.
As parents is not clear,
those passings surely would have
been horrific in themselves.
They have in the autumn of 18,
74 when Microsoft was in
London and Shallow Cambridge.
On hearing the news,
both boys returned immediately to Sussex.
That father had been killed by a pistol,
shot to the head of their mother,
had been strangled.
The police immediately
ruled out murder suicide,
but Microsoft in sherlock knew better.
A lonely and depressed Charlotte,
but found release in
the arms of another man.
I'm discovering the affair.
Roger.
He had strangled his wife in a frenzy
and then stagger to the stables where you
attend the pistol on himself.
The two sons.
Did you still have this room,
a capital examination of the scene
coupled with that inside knowledge of the
state of their parents' marriage,
the man who had been the subject
of Charlotte's affection,
and therefore the indirect cause of the
tragedy was a man of privilege by the
name of Lord Tap Clinton.
He discretes the left the
area after the deaths,
but his actions left a deep
seated resentments of titles,
men in the heart of Sherlock,
this family tragedy,
his homes at the age of 20.
I left him with a deep seated
business against his mother,
apart from his brother.
She was the only person who had ever
shown him love and affection and from all
of this,
what he decided he needed was
a complete change of scenery
from earliest boyhood.
SHELLAC had been fascinated
with the American west.
They wanted to travel to America
and payers way for some time,
so mycroft advanced him some
money from his father's estate.
He left for the new world in early 18,
75.
When he arrived in New York.
He became fascinated by the
theater scene in Manhattan.
It provided the escape that he needed.
In fact,
he loved the scene so much that he
drifted into a theatrical troupe in the
autumn of [inaudible] 75 because
Victorian society in America,
as well as in England,
considered acting less than
reputable occupation homes,
chose not to tarnish his family,
named by calling himself Mr Sherlock.
After a brief running in Manhattan,
the three went on tour that
took them as far as Chicago.
Those Korea on the American stage
lasted for less than a year.
Homes found the work absorbing and soon
became adept at the professional skills
of makeup and disguise.
Disability benefited him greatly and later
cases where he recreated himself into
everything from an Italian
priest to an old woman
to obtain realistic details for the
working class and criminal roles.
He played on stage homes ventured into
dangerous neighborhoods in New York and
other cities.
That is true visitors.
There's often proved hazardous,
requiring the cooperation
of the local police.
These excursions also gave homes,
contacts,
and information that he was able to
draw on during his later professional
career.
As he followed police investigations
in the cities he was touring.
He began to realize the practical
value of the scientific knowledge.
You had gains from his boyhood
experiments and his cambridge education,
bloodstains poisons mud caked on shoes,
liquid left in glasses,
his scientific way of looking at
such as revealed forensic evidence,
which he was able to pass on to
the police for the first time.
He began to seriously consider taking
up detective work professionally.
He imagined himself something
entirely new to the Victorian era,
a scientific detective.
This motive was to power him
through the rest of his life.
After 18 months of traveling around,
the United States almost decided it was
time to return to the country of his
birth on resends in London.
He founds lodging just around the
corner from the British Museum.
He began running errands for private
detectives carrying out such distasteful
duties as gathering
evidence for divorce cases,
but all the while he was picking up the
basics of detective work to further this
work.
He revived his study of science
with a focus on chemistry,
botany,
and anatomy
offer a year also,
Hamza was ready to branch off and
start his own detective agency.
His first cases were domestic and routine
revolving around minus civil disputes.
He walked onto cultivate his
relationship with the police,
passing on information that would
help them crack a case in return.
The police past clients
onto him the year 18,
88 was a fortunate one
for Sherlock Holmes.
Scans will have left the London police
in a situation that then they were open
to the up and coming to tax if the case
which has become known as the musgrave
ritual was his first high profile case
establishing his superior powers of
deduction ends for us to investigation
to a fascinated public case.
Got underway when Holmes
was cooled by a university,
Acquaintance Reginald Musgrave to have
musgraves domestic staff had disappeared
following their dismissal for
reading a secret family documents,
calls of the musgrave ritual
items not only solve the case,
but uncovered the crown of Kenny Charles
the fest which had been missing for 200
years as a result of the fame garnered
from the musgrave ritual homes was
invited to give a series of lectures
to instruct the newly formed criminal
investigation department.
Won't cid the brilliance.
Twenty four year old now found himself
in lightening hard bitten Korea cops on
anatomy,
chemistry and botany.
He also,
at this point,
knew enough about geology to
identify soil on clothing and shoes
and
more and more detectives now goes into
the habits of consulting with homes when
they reached an impasse
in their investigations,
even though they hated to admit this,
the young Pii would invariably provide
them with the breakthrough that they
needed in order to crack a case.
In 18,
81 homes began lodging with a man who
would become inextricably tied to himself.
Dr John Watson.
The address was two t one b Baker Street
Watson was a young medic who had just
returned from Afghanistan and was looking
for a cheap place to live on the first
meeting.
Once it was fascinated that homes
deduced that he had recently been in
Afghanistan without him having profit.
That information from that
moment on Watson was perks,
fares part home seemed delighted to share
his home with the affable Dr Watson,
the two men would go onto for the
partnership that has been an equals in the
annals of criminal investigation
as same as his reputation grew.
He attracted more and more
affluent clients and was
able to charge higher fees.
These hyphae cases subsidized others in
which he helps people who could only pay
a small fee or no fee at all.
He wants,
says that the status of my clients is
of less interest to me than the interest
of his case.
What he was after,
what cases that challenged him.
His greatest challenge came and his
ongoing hunt for London's master criminal
Professor Moriarty.
In order to avoid Moriarty's
criminal organization.
Holmes was forced to
flee Europe in late 18,
91,
but the criminal masterminds pursued
the great detective and it's a climactic
struggle occurred.
Top Theater Reichenbach
falls in Switzerland.
It appears that both men fall to their
death and the funeral is held for the
world's greatest detective.
However,
homes,
his body was never recovered
and indeed he was not.
Debt for three years,
though he allowed the world,
including Dr Watson to
believe that he was dead.
This period is known by biographers
as the great hiatus in 18,
94.
He was suddenly back on
the scene explaining to a
bewildered Dr Watson that he
had faked his death to get
moriarty's henchmen off his back.
Ten years later,
homes retard to a small farm in Sussex
downs where he took up beekeeping in
1908.
He came out of retirement in order to
aid his governments working as a double
agents.
He masterminded the
capture of a German spike.
It is believed he kept
busy with intelligence work
during the first world war.
There is no record of homes
is activities after the war.
So when did Sherlock Holmes die?
The answer is obvious.
Just consider the Plethora of TV shows,
movies,
and books on the man and he will surely
agree that Sherlock Holmes had never
died,
just as he had never lived.
Sherlock Holmes.
He's a complete work of fiction,
the creation of a writer by
the name of Arthur Conan doyle.
That's if you've spent the last 20 minutes
believing that you are learning the
history of a real life human being,
you're certainly not alone.
In a recent poll,
21 percent of respondents thought that
the greatest sleuth of Baker Street
really did exist,
which just goes to show that sometimes
fiction is stranger than truth.
That's you might notice that this video
is published on April first April fools
to everybody,
so I really hope you enjoyed
that episode of biographics.
If you did this,
a couple of things you could do right now.
One is hit that like button below.
Also,
if you want more stuff like this,
we put our brand new videos
every Monday and every Thursday,
so hit that subscribe button below and
subscribe button doesn't do what it used
to on.
If you actually want to get a
notification about these videos,
please do hit that bell button next to
the subscribe button and that'll send you
a notification every time,
every Monday and Thursday
wouldn't put out a new video.
Also,
if you want to watch
something else right now,
stuff from the archive
over there on the race
and as always,
thank you for watching.